Britain's numbers are increasing
exponentially with the death toll
doubling every three days makeshift
morgues are being built like this one on
an ice rink in Milton Keynes to meet
those grim demands meanwhile frontline
health care workers continue to make
hurried preparations where personal
protection equipment is in short supply
as it widely is they're fashioning
solutions from hardware shops even
resorting to seaside snorkels and school
science class goggles the government
insists millions of items are in the
delivery pipeline but in many places
they aren't arriving quickly enough I am
now setting the goal of 100,000 tests
per day by the end of this month that is
the goal and I am determined that we
will get there testing is another
crucial part of the UK government's
response that for now is wanting this is
a drive-through testing centre in an
Ikea carpark in Northwest London it's
one of five across the country finally
allowing frontline health care staff to
get a test for Kovac 19:00 if they're
self isolating at home with symptoms and
find out whether they've actually got
the disease and if they haven't to allow
them to get back to work quickly we
spoke to one National Health Service
Worker who'd just been tested she didn't
want to be identified
and out of the 50 people that were
deployed only seven turned up for work
everybody's worried everybody's worried
we're working with no PPE lots I think
lots of NHS it could have been hit
already with they're gonna come down
sick with critics saying it's too little
too late it's emerged that private
research labs who have valuable testing
equipment and expertise have so far had
their offers to help rebuffed by the
government criticizing not criticizing
it's the question of policy the
government must either have a policy
that they do not need or do not want
help from the sort of decentralized
university labs around the country all
their policy is that that would be
useful and I'm not in a position to know
how those policy discussions are gone
but my feeling is that's where they need
to be clear either we're part of the
solution or we're not and here comes the
Sun it's not all bad news the famous
crossing at Abbey Road Studios got a new
lick of paint in the unusual absence of
beetle fans taking selfies ready for
life after coronavirus Jonah Hall
al-jazeera London